v30 la nouvelle bombe atomique de vg
écran qhd plus oled 6 pouces full vie
jeunes qualité sonore incroyable avec
bang & olufsen objectif grand-angle
processeur snapdragon 835 octas core
cadencé à 2,45 giga hertz reconnaissance
faciale et vocale android 7 points un
point de nougat j'ai pu l'essayer à
l'ifa dans la capitale allemande lors
d'un passage express et vous allez voir
il est un roi yan lgv 30
le tout nouveau smartphone de lg qui il
faut le reconnaître fondamentalement est
une vraie bombe
en termes de caractéristiques techniques
et là un écran 6 pouces qhd plus oled
une vraie qualité
quand on regarde la démonstration c'est
juste incroyable
l'écran est vraiment super
impressionnant il a une qualité de
dingue
les écrans oled de toute façon en termes
de qualité on peut pas rivaliser
c'est vraiment extraordinaire un écran
de 1880 par 1440
vous avez une double caméra arrière 16
mégapixels et 13 mégapixels autant fait
que la caméra à l'avant ne soit que de 5
mégapixels al'avantage de pouvoir
reconnaître votre visage pour pouvoir
effectivement déverrouiller au niveau
faciale vous pouvez aussi déverrouiller
grâce à votre voix il reconnaît qu'à 35
de voix et vous pouvez déverrouiller
grâce à ça c'est quand même très
pratique il faut le reconnaître
vous avez 4 gigabits de mémoire
heures et 64 giga de stockage à
l'intérieur que vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 2 t à
c'est juste la bâtisse nick 3300
millions père alors ça va faire le job
et surtout ce qui est impressionnant
c'est la taille de l'écran on n'est pas
tout à fait sûre du bord à bord vous
avez un tout petit bord mais il reste
quand même minime ça permet d'avoir une
vraie qualité sont qu'un écran oled
comme ça on en profite on est en pleine
immersion c'est vraiment génial c'est un
téléphone qui est quand même ultra fin
on a conservé une prise jack ici on m'a
pas c'est juste génial lorsque vous
travaillez vous voulez brancher un micro
dessus c'est vraiment très pratique
le petit
haut-parleurs qui est très discret la
caméra qui était très discrète aussi sur
le dessus à l'arrière le flash le double
capteur en 'très bien' pixels et en 16
mégapixels vous pouvez dès leur ouïe est
ici et vous avez un partenariat avec
bang & olufsen pour profiter vraiment
d'une qualité audio extraordinaire haut
parleurs et micro sur le bas vous avez
ici votre spot brancher votre carte
micro sd vous régler le volume
directement ici c'est vraiment un
appareil qui est magnifique c'est la
star ce salon est certifié ip 68
complètement résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière et le point qui est
extrêmement favorable ce qu'ils
appellent le crunch où vous allez sur
notre image sélectionnée une partie une
zone que vous voulez film et vous
cliquez sur le point où vous allez je
vais vous zoomez sur un zoom qui est
extrêmement doux c'est très très très
pratique
ça vous fait le zoom dézoom aussi c'est
très doux on va avoir aussi un
stabilisateur donc pas une image qui va
être complètement secours et enfin en
termes de qualité pour filmer si vous
êtes sur youtube si vous faites de la
vidéo pleine de la photo c'est vraiment
un produit que je vous recommande
lorsque vous faites de la vidéo vous
pouvez choisir entre 15 et fait
différent pour colorisées votre image
alors normalement quand on fait de la
vidéo professionnelle on va pas
colorisées directement sur le téléphone
mais si vous voulez par exemple les
choses rapidement avoir une image
statique est très sympa que vous
partagez rapidement sur les réseaux
sociaux avec ce smartphone vous pouvez
le faire
c'est vraiment un outil jeudi qu'elle
est dédié en menaçant aux professionnels
comme aux amateurs
bien évidemment on retrouve du bluetooth
5.0 et un chargeur
usb c'est pour trouve également une
recharge par induction haut niveau sur
smartphone avec le poil comme pete
charge 3.0 c'est difficile à prononcer
processeur bien évidemment c'est un
snapdragon à l'intérieur vous avez ici
sur le côté la possibilité de rajouter
des raccourcis pour mettre vos
applications favorites
c'est vraiment pratique non c'est un
téléphone qui est vraiment sympa qui est
pratique pour faire de la vidéo qui a
une qualité d'écran est exceptionnel
vous allez pouvoir en profiter que vous
soyez amateur de photo amateur de vidéos
pouvant vous le faire un usage
professionnel
c'est vraiment un outil qui est très
discret qui est très fin là on est que
le v30 en main il ya le v30 plus
également qu'il va sortir pour l'instant
toujours pas depuis l'annoncé par contre
c'est un smartphone sera disponible
normalement à partir du mois de novembre
à toute mesure aujourd'hui sur ce
nouveau smartphone de lg le lg eve et 30
mois c'est un smartphone qui m'a
vraiment bluffé dit - vous ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est ce que
c'est un smartphone qui pourrait vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
smartphones de chez lg est ce que vous
envisageriez de rester chez lg pourquoi
pas d'aller chez lg medimat ou sans
commentaire élus en discutent ensemble
je vous invite à vous abonner à l'achat
n'est pas ce qui aura encore plus de
contenu high-tech encore plus de contenu
pour vous aider à réussir votre
stratégie youtube pas parler
d'énormément de produits et en ce moment
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
tests et de produits à venir vous invite
également à poser toutes vos questions
sur twitter
@ monsieur greu et avec le hashtag ask
monsieur dreux quant à moi je vous donne
rendez vous très très très rapidement
pour prochaine vidéo et d'ici là portez
vous bien
salut
[Musique]